[Music]
hi it's Michelle from Lapland beauty
science chemistry PhD skin Kennard and
human guinea pig today I'm going to be
talking about my favorite skincare
products of 2019 if you like talking
nerdy about Beauty make sure you like
this video subscribe to my channel and
click the notification bell so you don't
miss any videos for 2018 I went through
a list of all my empties I really really
need to read I my hair I tried to iron
that background once and it melted but
in 2019 I didn't actually finish many
products because I was trying out so
much stuff when I started making a list
of all the products I really liked in
2019 I ended up with a really long list
so I decided to limit it to products
that I discovered in 2019
I also limited myself to one product per
brand and I left off a lot of products
that I've recently discovered and loved
just in case I don't love them as much a
few months down the line I've definitely
forgotten a bunch of products that I
really loved in 2019 so for 2020 I am
going to be more meticulous about
keeping a list this is the vitamin C
serum from the inky list I really like
this product because it is water free
which means that the ascorbic acid
doesn't decompose over time anywhere
near as quick as a watery formula it's
also one of the smoothest water free
ascorbic acid products I've tried it's
not as gritty as some of the other
formulas which I find it tends to be a
bit too strong for me of its gritty the
large crystals take a while to dissolve
and then when they do they have sort of
concentrated hot spots on my skin I tend
to apply this over a watery product so
that the vitamin C crystals have time to
dissolve and hopefully spread out a bit
to again avoid that hot spot problem if
your skin is sensitive to acids be
really careful this type of water free
form like can be too strong for some
people in 2019 I also discovered the
Ordinaries glycolic acid toner in
general I found that the Ordinaries acid
products aren't actually that effective
on my skin but this one is nice and
gentle but still effective it's also
very light and watery so it's easy
laya under other products and it's
gentle enough that I can use it with
other actives in my routine I've also
found that this is really effective on
my armpits as its ureter and I've got a
blog post about how that works
linked in the description this is the
Kate Ryan total nutrition night repair
complex this is my favorite all-in-one
product technically I've started trying
this out in 2018 but I only posted about
it in 2019 if you look at the
ingredients list for this it is a mile
long it contains a whole bunch of really
really nice ingredients it has things
like niacinamide retinol acetate which
is a weaker form of retinol it also has
antioxidants and centella I think
there's also peptides inert there's
ubiquinone there's just a whole bunch of
ingredients because it's so gentle I
find that it's really nice and uh Neera
tating especially for nights when my
skin is a bit irritated and can't take
anything stronger
I love that I wake up with glowy plump
skin after using this it also has a pump
top which is my favorite type of
packaging I really love this I use it
all the time when I need to have nice
skin the next day and I don't want to
risk anything irritating I recently made
a video about my favorite sunscreens and
these three I discovered in 2019 so they
are the ultraviolet supreme screen pure
ito-san chela green level unscented Sun
and as clear as day moisturizer all
three of these have fantastic textures
and they contain some of the newer photo
stable UV filters none of them give you
a white cast which is really important
if you want to find out more about these
sunscreens you can check out my Holy
Grail sunscreens video my favorite
cleansing balm at the moment is that
then I met you
living cleansing balm I met Charlotte
char of psychic lamb at Jakarta
ex-beauty earlier this year and she
gifted me her cleansing Dewar I really
liked that gel cleanser as well but this
is definitely my favorite it is a really
rich cleansing balm it has a really
gorgeous texture and it rinse us off
while leaving a small amount of oil on
your skin so that it doesn't feel dried
out it's amazing at room
make up has a first cleanse I usually
follow it up with a cleansing gel and if
I'm at home and I haven't been wearing
makeup that J is sometimes I'll use it
alone the next product I have is the
indeed last BQ Shiori face pads
I think the QL is a bit of an overrated
product it is not really a rational
replacement as it's often marketed as I
wrote a really detailed blog post about
why I came to this conclusion and this
led to one of the nicest brand
interactions I've ever had the founder
of indeed labs actually sent me a
message saying that even though she was
a bit disappointed with the conclusion
since this was they hero product at the
time she appreciated my honesty and
integrity in writing the post which is
really nice because I'm sort of used to
brands being quite offended when I
criticize their hero ingredients anyway
despite that I do think the QL is a
really promising ingredient as well as
the QL these pads include a ton of
niacinamide which is a really nice
soothing ingredient really good for
irritated skin I think the combination
of Baku chill and niacinamide is why
these pads work so well on my skin I
wake up with really nice plump smooth
skin after using them this is the zelans
pal D treatment drops the D in the name
refers to dehydrate cholesterol which is
also known as pro vitamin D these drops
also have linoleic acid I mostly found
these useful when I was using tretinoin
for the first time and I had lots and
lots of peeling and irritation these
really calmed down my skin the problem
is these are quite pricey so I'm not
sure I would repurchase it unless I was
having lots of problems with irritated
skin so if that's a problem for you
these might be worth the price onto my
favorite body products of 2019 this is
soap and Glory's smooth Easter breakfast
scrub I'm sorry if I look really sweaty
it is really hot in Australia right now
and I am under these lights I am
basically wilting I'm not a huge fan of
using scratchy scrubs on my face because
my skin is quite sensitive especially
now that I'm
lots of trash anon and it's dehydration
prone and I found that that sort of
irritation just dries my skin out on my
body it's a completely different story
this is amazing it smells so good it has
a maple syrup smell which just makes me
think of pancakes and it's such a
delicious smell it's actually not that
Scratchy
and because it's made of sugar and salt
it goes down the drain without leaving a
massive mess in your shower
fun fact when I featured this on my
Instagram feed the person who formulated
it actually commented on my post which
was really cool it's a nice reminder
that there are actually people behind
these products and so all of those myths
about how different products are going
to kill you there are people making
these products they don't want to kill
you they are human they're not evil I
[Music]
also discovered a bunch of really nice
gentle shower gels this year this is the
necessary wash it is really lovely it
has a really cool mechanism up the top
it twists and then a little hole opens
up it just looks so lovely in your
bathroom and it's really nice and gentle
it has lots of glycerin it's got a nice
in amide it's really nice for cold
weather when you've got really dry skin
it doesn't strip the hydration from your
skin and I think we tend to just ignore
our bodies a lot of the time don't
forget that skincare ingredients that
are good for your face are also good for
your body I also discovered Bioderma
Saturday Michelle oil this year which I
got in Europe unfortunately it is not
available in Australia I think when I
posted about how much I loved it a whole
bunch of people asked me how to get it
and the biodome appeals weren't that
happy it is really good again really
nourishing lots of glycerin lots of non
ionic surfactants that won't strip your
skin this was a lifesaver for me when I
was in Europe and it was a lot drier
than I was used to it was also great in
winter here in Australia so if you are
in Europe or you have friends going to
Europe this is probably one of the
things that should be on your wish list
a shower gel that I really really love
this year is the happy hippy shower gel
from lush I don't take a lot of baths so
a lot of the time I don't get to use my
lush bath bombs but this shower gel I've
been using almost every day this year it
is just a really nice solid shower gel
lots of glycerin so again it doesn't
strip your skin that much it also smells
amazing it has a really nice bright
citrus smell which I love if your skin
is sensitive to citrus oils then
obviously this is probably not a great
choice for you but for my skin this is
fantastic so those were my 2019 skincare
favorites have you tried any of these
products what did you think of them
leave me a comment letting me know if
you liked this video I'd appreciate it
if you gave it a thumbs up and subscribe
to my channel you can also follow me on
instagram at lab muffin Beauty size for
lots of skincare and beauty tips check
out my blog lab muffin comm film Oh
beauty science and I'll see you next
time
you